صدفه غريبه وجميله كانت الحسناء
الارجنتينيه جورجينا رودريغيز على موعد
معها حين دخل عليها النجم البرتغالي
كريستيانو رونالدو في متجر غوتشي حيث كانت
تعمل كبائعه ليلتقيان لاول مره وتبدا
بينهما قصه حب عظيمه اصبحت على مراه
العالم منذ ذلك الحين هذا الحب اصبح باب
السعاده جورجينا التي لم تكن قبل التاريخ
لقائها برنالدو صاحبه شهره لتنتقل بعد
حبهما الى عالم الشهره والثراء وتصبح احد
اهم وجوه الازياء والدعايه في العالم لم
تغيب جورجينا عن حياه شركه رونالدو رياضيه
في كل لحظاتها الجميله منها والسيئه كانت
معه ايام احتفاله بدوري الابطال مع ريال
مدريد لعده سنوات وكانت جزءا من الفرح
الخاص به حين توج مع بلاده بكاس امم
اوروبا ودور الامم الاوروبيه وايضا كانت
معه
التي بدات منذ خرج من اسبانيا واكتملت في
مانشستر يونايتد وصلت الى ذروتها عاقبه
خروج المؤلم من كاس العالم جورجينا كانت
ايضا خير لرونالدو في اصعب اللحظات حين
راى منافسه الاول عالميا ليونيل ميسي يتوج
بكاس العالم فهي الارجنتينيه التي لم
تحتفل بفوز بلادها بالبطوله الاكبر حفاظا
على مشاعر شريكها البرتغالي الجانب الاخر
من حياه جورجينا مع رونالدو انها سيده
منزل ماهر فهي طالما ظهرت بمقاطع فيديو
وهي تعتني في منزلها ايضا وايضا باطفالهما
حتى الذين لم تنجبهم الحسناء الارجنتينيه